[Musique]
aujourd'hui une grande étape dans
l'histoire de cette zone de protection
naturelle agricole et forestière
killzone qui a été créée en 2010 et dont
le périmètre a été finalisée en 2013
1 c'est vraiment un atout essentiel
aujourd'hui ont signé une charte une
charte d'engagement de tous les
partenaires aussi bien l'état les
collectivités locales les acteurs
opérationnels du monde agricole nos
machines agriculture mais aussi
forestier donc tous les partenaires se
sont engagés dans une démarche
collective de protection et l'animation
de la zp et n'affichant que c'est une
démarche forte
le préfet l'a 10 et c'est pas figé on
est là pour compléter si c'est
nécessaire etc et donc on est vraiment
cette dynamique là et ce à un moment
assez fort parce que c'est le résultat
d'un travail collectif qui montre que
tous les acteurs sont engagés dans cette
la protection de ce territoire là qui
est un atout formidable d'ailleurs pour
le projet de paris saclay rang dans
cette dynamique la vie par ailleurs il
ya une autre dimension qu'on a signé
aujourd'hui avec la chambre
d'agriculture et monsieur le préfet qui
est un protocole pour participer au
financement du programme d'action c'est
que cette zone de protection naturelle
agricole forestière c'est un territoire
avec une charte d'engagement et une
protection à la non urbanisation mais il
ya aussi la volonté d'un programme
d'actions pour valoriser accompagner le
monde agricole accompagné les zones le
protéger dans une plus grande
valorisation et nous avons signé
aujourd'hui avec la chambre
d'agriculture et monsieur le préfet un
protocole qui fait que des gays les
financements que non que qu'on était
censé faire en termes de coûts de
compensation agricole nous les
fléchiront et c'était la volonté qu'on a
essayé de pousser nous les fréchon sur
les actions agricoles du programme
d'action global
ce travail collectif et je me réjouis
qu'on avance favorablement dans ce
territoire où le monde agricole
d'ailleurs une
une dynamique très forte aussi bien
économique comme en termes d'innovation
qui utilisent rejoint parfaitement
l'objectif de ce territoire quels
territoires d'innovation de la france
[Musique]
où